my name is Jody Nelson I am NOT the
former foreign minister of the UK I
noticed in the announcement of today
that my boss David Miliband was the the
first preference which is understandable
and that even the in adjusting the
schedule unfortunately they left in part
of his you know glamorous past and so
the best thing is I am going to send
that to my mom so she could see how
accomplished I've truly become the first
american jew foreign minister to the UK
in any case i am the senior vice
president of policy and practice at the
International Rescue Committee and I
think the best way to tell you what that
is is really to start the conversation
today along the path of my career and
and at IRC I really tried to bridge
theory and practice and bring academic
research and most notably social science
research into the practice space and I
took the job with David in large part
because I was so excited by the
opportunity to do that at IRC and so I
hope we can end the conversation today
with ideas about what that might look
like for some of you and certainly
opportunities that we see at IRC and in
the community writ large for continuing
to bridge that gap let me just say two
things two minutes about IRC for those
of you who don't know the International
Rescue Committee is a half a billion a
little bit more dollar non-governmental
organization that works along the
trajectory of a refugees life experience
we provide direct services in places of
war and humanitarian crisis and we also
resettle refugees
across the US and increasingly provide
technical advice about resettlement in
Europe as well so we are standardly
known as kind of a humanitarian relief
agency and a resettlement agency truth
be told we stay in countries for
sometimes up to 30 or 40 years and so in
many cases our work is not just what we
consider emergency relief but is much
more characteristic of development
working with communities working with
ministries and working across a set of
outcomes related to people's life health
education violence prevention economic
well-being and empowerment so I'm going
to read my comments today but I really
I'm going to try to drive to the end of
the comments so that we can have a
conversation and I and I hope I hope
it's pitched right for this audience
because it's not at all like what we
talked about this morning and it has
nothing to do with Yale or Connecticut
and and hopefully will serve as stimulus
to get us into some conversations that
we haven't had yet and I'm reading
because I have a bit of the flu and I
don't quite trust the connection between
my brain and my words so I hope you'll
bear with me today so I am indeed I'm
delighted to be here to talk about
humanitarian aid and especially keen to
discuss what you've noted as the title
of the conference today the next
generation of research and partnership
that a program like this one can enable
indeed this type of collaboration is
essential to finding solutions to some
of the more pressing challenges we face
as an aid community it's also been a
constant in my career and is central to
I our C's organizational strategy one of
our lasting commitments at IRC is to
make sure our programs focus on results
and are based on the best available
evidence where we see a need
more evidence we invest in generating
evidence where that gap in knowledge is
hurting our ability to help people
around the world I'm going to do a few
things in the next few minutes first
I'll describe what many people note as
the current refugee or humanitarian
crisis but I'll try to persuade you that
what we see today is not a punctuated
crisis but instead the most recent
signal of a system that was not
deliberately developed to respond to the
scale and scope of needs we see today in
the world I'll remind us of the founding
of humanitarianism as a set of
principles or norms of behavior and
these are currently and clearly
insufficient tools to meet needs and
allocate resources in a world of
multiple crises and political
decision-making
there are many symptoms of this mismatch
but there are also signs of innovation
and progress both in the policy arena
and in the tools and approaches we use
in humanitarian practice I'll describe
both briefly I'll conclude with what I
see is a tremendous opportunity that
these challenges and signs of progress
present for a community like this one
Interdisciplinary lodged in an excellent
university and interested I hope in the
intersection of theory and practice I'll
start off with a few ideas but what I'm
really looking forward to is the
discussion this I'm sure will be the
best part of the discussion so first is
this are you can you hear me okay
and most people today are talking about
a refugee crisis and referring to the
conflict and displacement in the Middle
East where people suffering from ongoing
civil war in Syria are living without
the protection of international law
spilling into and threatening the
development of neighboring countries
Jordan and Lebanon and faced with
increasingly limited options to return
home integrate locally or resettle in
another country indeed you heard this
morning about the very very small
percentage I think it's
percent of people lucky enough to
resettle in America a few statistics in
addition to the ones on the slide are
worth repeating over the past six years
the war in Syria has taken more than
four hundred thousand lives this data is
already dated given the chemical warfare
we observed in the last week or so an
estimated 11 million Syrians have fled
their home since the outbreak of the
Civil War in March 2011 six million
people are displaced inside the country
and countries surrounding Syria host
more than four point eight million
registered Syrian refugees I'm sure you
noted as I did the terrible tragedy
during 2015 and 16 where refugees and
migrants attempted to cross the
Mediterranean for Europe at the very
least 5,000 people perished and trying
to cross the Mediterranean there are
still today more than 65,000 refugees
stranded in Greece after European
countries have decided to close their
borders no matter where they are the
vast majority of these people the Syrian
displaced are still living in poverty
they are unable to work struggling to
afford and get access to health care
rent or to send their children to school
there's no doubt that the endless
suffering produced by this war and by
the failure of the international
community to protect and/or resettle
refugees from the region is an
indictment of the humanitarian system
and even more so of the missing
political leadership to resolve the
conflict in the Middle East but it's
just as clear that seeing the Middle
East as the beginning or ultimate signal
of a crisis isn't right on maps state of
the humanitarian system in 2015
describes the problem well that it's not
so much that the humanitarian system is
now broken and that this is a sign of
that but instead that it was not
designed in the first place to meet the
scale of need and crises going on in the
world before talking a little bit about
the origination of the humanitary
system I wanted to share with you two
other regional crises that IRC and peer
agencies like us are responding to
around the world and I have a very
simple point in showing you these slides
is simply to talk about the scale of
need that it exists in the world outside
of the Middle East and including other
regions so this first slide is a slide
that speaks to the flow of people
currently in and around East Africa for
those of you who don't know because it
hasn't been very prominent in repressed
people surrounding this region so South
Sudan in Kenya and Ethiopia in parts of
Uganda Tanzania and camps in Burundi and
elsewhere are experiencing the
confluence of drought famine and ongoing
displacement this is I thought one of
the better slides we've looked at as a
leadership team at IRC just to show the
enormous flux of people going in and out
of countries that can't protect them and
provide services I was just in Kenya a
couple weeks ago and perhaps the most
striking thing to me was not in a
displaced context where people are
actually getting services but outside of
the camps where Kenyans not displease
people in an area called Turkana are
suffering tremendously from drought and
famine in fact in all of my travels at
IRC and elsewhere I hadn't seen that
kind of malnutrition and it was quite
devastating the second slide I wanted to
share again making a point that the
scale of need exists in but outside of
the Middle East as well this is a slide
we looked at just this week at IRC at a
leadership discussion about the lake
Chad basin so that includes countries we
share Nigeria Chad Mali and IRC is you
can see those little black houses I
think that's right black and blue houses
IRC is operating within that region but
what I found particularly
striking about the slide is where you
see the black and yellow lines indicate
that there's no so without military
escorts people can't get in to deliver
aid to people and I use this slide also
to just show the proliferation of
violence so in this area Boko Haram now
linked explicitly to Isis has control of
areas that are you know continuing to
cause violence and suffering and also
again denying aid to people so what
would the humanitarian founders say
about how to respond to these types of
regional crises I thought was so
interesting to hear Katherine's
introduction this morning about values
and the value that we all bring to the
table today and in our lives about being
a humanitarian and actually I'm going to
be provocative about that because my own
sense is that those values and
principles are failing us there is no
doubt that the humanitarian system as as
a as an entity of actions and
organizations and intent was founded
based on principles in fact it goes back
to the 1800s when people described the
beginning of the Red Cross or of the
Geneva Convention they often talk about
a Swiss businessman named original who
in visiting northern Italy during
Napoleon's you know terror and military
campaign witnessed firsthand the horrors
of war and the need for independent
neutral objective relief societies or
people who were protected and could
provide protection and could enter those
situations and provide relief the book
that he wrote which is called a memory
of Solferino was a testament to what he
saw and the need for that kind of
independent protection of people during
war
he advocated for the formation of relief
societies and the adoption of a
government treaty recognizing the
neutrality of the agency that was
created in this case it was the ICRC or
Red Cross and allowing it to provide
neutral aid in a war zone
why is this important today for me I
think it's an important reminder that
humanitarian action was born out of
charity and volunteerism in contrast to
how it truly operates today and it's
also a reminder that these principles in
and of themselves protection neutrality
the provision of safety to people
non-combatants during war are failing as
we see in the world today these are
exactly the principles that are being
disregarded the bombing of hospitals in
Syria chemical warfare ongoing suffering
throughout the Horn in East Africa and
then lake Chad basin are just examples
if you take a look in fact at the actual
system of humanitarian aid and this
doesn't really make this point but I'll
make the point for you this is meant to
show the various kinds of entities and
organizations that are involved in what
we call the humanitarian aid system and
to me a few things are worth noting
first the affected communities that big
circle in the center are definitely at
the center but I would argue that that
circle should actually be quite small in
terms of the decision-making power and
voice that affected communities actually
have in determining the flow of
resources and to the other reason I like
to include this slide is it just
suggests the dynamism and relationships
and I would argue politics that happen
across the many organizations of the
humanitarian aid system principally
international NGOs the Red Cross the Red
Crescent donors host governments and UN
agencies are probably among the agencies
where the the politics of decision
making
is right and in many ways more
determinant of how resources flow than
actual need so so make this is this is
instrumental to understanding why the
system itself is not working to meet
people's needs we see the politics of
decision making in how resources are
allocated over time and again getting us
out of the Middle East but still
understanding the the depth of need that
exists in the Middle East which you can
see in more recent years this slide is
meant to show the gap between the money
that is needed and the actual money that
is raised to respond to emergencies so
just to be specific the yellow is unmet
requirements and the dark color is what
is a what is quantified as you know we
need X amount of money to respond to
this the second way you see the politics
of decision making and that values are
not driving the response to humanitarian
need is that the press and
understandably given how our world works
the presses is largely but let's say the
degree to which crises show up in the
press and provide a year that drives
public perception of the need to respond
is arguably a bigger lever than the
existence of need and the scale of that
need so this slide is meant to show that
visa via the Ebola crisis I find this
data really striking so what it shows
right as we all remember in 2014 the
Ebola the Ebola crisis raged across
across West Africa sorry IRC was
actually in all of the country Sierra
Leone Liberia could've are responding to
that crisis and working with others to
do so but what's fascinating if you look
down at the data is that the money in
2014 is we're sorry the big bar is where
the money was in 2014 and if you
right before and right after you can see
the money going away from those
countries so imagine the effect this has
on the region right in one year
responding to a crisis an enormous
amount of international assistance
enters the region and within two years
that money is gone the donors are
leaving what region can absorb that kind
of resource and what kind of change can
happen in the span of such a short
period i meant to include this slide
because i think it's another good
example of the the reality that politics
and decision-making drive how resources
flow through the system so just as in
the first slide where you see the
affected communities at the center but
really that circle should be small and
this one i meant to show as well that in
this case local organizations and then
if you think even below that the people
that they are serving and represent are
at the end of the chain i think it's
also interesting to note how resources
flow to many different actors in the
system so while the UN can get money
from donor governments and give that
money to international NGOs
international NGOs can also get money
from donor governments and the same so
on and so on
so the third evidence i would i would
say that shows this kind of politics and
the lack of principles driving
humanitarian response have to do with
what we call it IRC the quality of money
that is allocated to meet needs and this
is something in recent may be the last
one or two years that has really been
well recognized by people commenting on
the aid system and very specifically
what I mean by the quality of money is
the structure of that money so
international NGOs local NGOs UN
agencies everybody who participates in
this enterprise receives resources
through grants through
contracts through agreements and
literally the structure of those
agreements and grants can affect the
efficiency and effectiveness of the aid
that's delivered for an organization
like IRC what we tend to find is that
our donors give very short term project
grants sometimes as as short as six
months they may renew those grants but
often there's a gap in between the grant
that we get in the grant that we need to
renew just last week I was talking to a
colleague of mine who was in South Sudan
and she was commenting on the healthcare
program in South Sudan and how an echo
grant a European community grant had
just run out and they had to fire all
the staff even though they knew within
three months they were going to get a
renewal of that echo grant so that's
just one example all donors have
different reporting requirements
different instruction that instructions
excuse me about how to measure the
progress of their work they struggle to
line up their grant giving with their
own budget cycles understandably and
there's often a gap between grants IRC
staff in many contexts as our pure
agencies I'm assuming have the same
experience often have to manage around
100 or 125 different grants in a
particular country with different
requirements and expectations this
quality of money deeply affects our
ability to respond to need these issues
of resources quantity quality where the
resources flow for how long they last
have been raised by many many
practitioners and policymakers in fact
2016 was supposed to be a year of
international leadership and agenda
setting for the humanitarian community
to grapple with and solve for these and
other issues but the Year revealed that
there isn't enough incentive to truly
tackle these issues in fact the refugee
and migration summits in the u.s. in
September 2016 were only the last of a
series of summits that
happened throughout the year the outcome
of literally hundreds of discussions and
conversations and commitments at the
world humanitarian summit is still hard
for us in the community to see I thought
these slides will also protect
particularly helpful I don't know how
many of you know about the world
humanitarian summit but it was supposed
to be the first and seminal event
gathering people actors organizations
policymakers practitioners Member States
from around the world to in essence
construct a reform agenda for
humanitarian aid and oh my good slide
isn't in there um so if you look at top
there was 3,000 individual and joint
commitments that was the device that the
summit organizers at the UN used to
drive resolution of those issues I had a
slide in here that simply lists the
thousands of commitments for those of us
in the community it's really not clear
what's happening next to me this speaks
to a lack of important leadership that
we see an international leadership that
we're lacking important you to note
things aren't all bad I've clearly tried
to communicate to you that the system is
political not principally driven and
that people's needs are not getting met
at the same time one unintended positive
consequence of the dramatic increase in
the displace these last year's is that
new organizations have joined the aid
community's efforts old organizations
have altered their direction to get more
involved and people are coming up with
new ways of doing business that
represent improvements in the toolkit we
use to deliver results for people I'll
give you a few examples the Middle East
crisis brought the World Bank to the
table in a different way the World Bank
is as you know a large multilateral
organization focused on development in
years past the World Bank excluded
countries of crisis and issues of
displacement from its rement
motivated in part by their inability to
help the middle east to access funds to
address displacement the World Bank has
since been on a path of reform to
increase the ADA provides to fragile
states to change the instruments that it
uses so that loans are available to
those countries and countries can access
them
and in fact they've increased the amount
of resources not zero-sum but absolute
that go to fragile countries that
experience large flows of displacement
the private sector has also increased
its engagement I love the example of
Starbucks hiring refugees in America
MasterCard Western Union LinkedIn Airbnb
thinking together about how to provide
solutions to refugees how to support
cash transfers to refugees in country
and how to really bring their business
savvy to bear there also have been new
and interesting ideas about innovative
financing insurance schemes humanitarian
impact bonds a global Islamic endowment
fund and private sector efforts to
increase risk financing in vulnerable
countries are all examples another
hopeful trend is that new partnerships
have developed to address humanitarian
need and help countries and communities
in crisis find solutions I'll give one
that comes from I our seas experience
where we are happily among the eight
semi-finalists of the MacArthur a
hundred million dollar and change
competition we have partners from sesame
and IRC in the room today this is an
amazing amazing opportunity and to me a
signal of the innovation that can be
stimulated when people are in need
basically with the hundred million
dollars you know if IRC gets it which is
of course part of the uncertainty we've
proposed to partner with Sesame Street
to
get proven models of early childhood
development through multimedia vehicles
to kids all over the Middle East and
that partnership where we are bringing
to bear IRCs footprint our
implementation experience our knowledge
of the Middle East populations with
Sesame's innovative and multi country
and many years of experience educating
kids plus MacArthur's private and fairly
flexible resources represents a real
opportunity to do things differently I
think the area where I'd like to drill
down and I think is also a sign of
tremendous progress and hope is as with
the MacArthur Opportunity has to do with
partnership between applied researchers
and agencies like IRC IRC privileges and
prioritizes the generation and use of
evidence in a way that we could not have
done 10 to 15 years ago and part of that
speaks to progress in the academic
community increasingly interdisciplinary
practice based actionable research has
really benefitted agencies like IRC so I
do think in conclusion that the
intersection of the challenges we see
and the opportunities that we're
experiencing provide universities like
this was an incredible opportunity I'll
give a few ideas here that I'm trying to
draw from the flow of this conversation
but I really do hope we can focus the
next 15 minutes or so thinking of ideas
that you see and thinking about how they
might be relevant to humanitarian action
so a few topics that come to my mind
first
I think the extremism and conflicts that
are ravaging the world are a
particularly important focus for
political scientists Boko Haram linked
to Isis and lake Chad basin
Isis in the Middle East the fact that
extremism can lodge in societies when
governments are not holding on to
legitimacy I'll seem like very important
topics to continue to grapple with in
international relations another one from
my perspective is multilateralism kind
of a dated term and certainly you know
in the study of international relations
something that I'm not sure still
retains any trendiness but for sure when
you look at the lack of power that the
UN has had the lack of international
leadership and this kind of reliance on
collective action but then proof that it
really doesn't work I would argue
there's a real opportunity to think
about the multilateral architecture in
the years ahead and certainly we know
that academics have played a role in
shaping UN reform and it's important
that they continue to do so with
tremendous fervor another and very
unrelated idea has to do with some of
what we talked about this morning the
fact of the matter is refugee
resettlement agencies across America
don't have very much data about
integration and we don't know enough
about the likelihood that people gain
employment that their kids go to school
and get well-educated that they
experience an uptick in their revenue
over years we have very suggestive
programmatic data but in terms of really
being able to make a case we haven't had
that kind of partnership with the
university finally and speaking more to
my own bias and social science training
I think the biggest Avenue for
partnership is in evaluative research
the fact of the matter is the aid
community doesn't have the skills and
competencies in perspective to conduct
the kind of empirical research that
social sciences do and can
partnerships to understand not just
what's happening which is something
we're quite good at but instead what
works to achieve results and at what
costs this partnership and evaluation
has really grown over the years but is
something where we are continued where
we continue to see needs that aren't met
and real opportunities for partnership
so my argument today I hope I made a
point to you about the inability of the
original founding of humanitarian action
based on principles to deal with the
scale and scope of needs we see we see
the mismatch every day as I'm sure you
do when you read the paper or work with
refugees or think about what's happening
in the world the humanitarian system
relies on money that isn't their
decisions ride on things that aren't
about need and are more about politics
the quality of the money distributed is
deeply affected by the very
understandable political needs of donors
to justify their use of money to their
publics and governments and the lack of
leadership and over reliance on
collective action that doesn't work have
been especially clear in the last year
in closing I do think that that that's
kind of a dire situation to present but
I hope we can turn now to the discussion
of opportunity and where research can
truly inform practice and policy thank
you oh sure I wanted to take a couple of
course yes sure and then I will call the
two other presenters and we'll continue
this conversation as panelists are
they've one or two very biting questions
yeah biting biting biting like you're
like dying to us even biting your
challenge burning questions that I know
Joey can have ails me would you like to
comment on how the language in the US
political discourse or public discourse
may be impacting the International
commitment to humanitarian work to
funding to donors or is the u.s. less
significant driver of those funds and in
the trajectory of funding than it might
like to acknowledge so it might be less
impactful than one might expect I mean
ultimately it's an empirical question of
whether right whether we see things
change because of the US administration
I I believe it's very very determinate
or my hypothesis is that it is not just
because we're seeing across the board a
trend toward nationalism and closing off
borders but also because the lack of
belief in foreign aid without much
justification for why really goes
against trends from both Republican and
Democratic administrations I mean I
think right so the u.s. cutting
contributions to the UN will have a
double effect on organizations and
people who are servicing those people
because we'll likely see a decrease in
for example you know the bureau
population of refugees I gray [ __ ] and
then that budget also goes to the UN and
that and then the UN money goes to the
same organization so like that picture
will lose on to accounts and that's
going to be a big dent for the overall
system which is already short of
resources but I hope that there is
innovation in private resources that
other countries
step up and that we don't see the kind
of ripple effect that I'm afraid or on
the verge of thing and one more question
of this great okay um well thank you so
much for that presentation it was
wonderful my name is Grace Benton I'm
from the Institute for the study of
international migration at Georgetown
University but I spent a little bit of
time working in refugee legal assistance
in Egypt a couple of years and I was
really struck by the graphic that you
showed I think of a slide number nine
which showed sort of the way that money
diffuses down from sort of the
international donors and things like
that and something I thought was missing
from that graphic was we had sort of
national organizations and local
organizations but there were no refugee
led organizations within that graphic
and they might go into local
organisations a little bit but which did
have like a really sort of narrow arrow
kind of extending down from from sort of
the international donor base but
something that got me thinking about
that was sort of in a previous session
I'm a gentleman in the audience sort of
referred to the capacity of refugee
communities and refugee led
organizations to really support refugees
and just how instrumental these kind of
groups and organizations are in
providing protection and support to
refugees and in our research at
Georgetown I mean we found time and
again just how it's really these kind of
kind of local interactions and sometimes
formal sometimes informal sort of
interactions that really I think are
making it possible for refugees and
displaced persons to make ends meet and
so in our discussion about kind of
harnessing available resources and
innovation I was curious if you could
talk a little bit about how the IRC
engages with refugee led organizations
as well as refugee communities in sort
of as as a
resource for refugee support and
protection so so a few things one I mean
I think people themselves probably don't
distinguish in-country themselves as
like I'm a refugee I'm going to lead an
organization I think local organizations
where people live regardless of whether
it's at a camp or in a host community or
if they're internally displaced or are a
huge part of the picture and certainly
IRC partners all up and down that chain
locally all the way up to
internationally I will say though my
experiences and I can give you an
example so in West Africa over the last
ten years or so IRC has done an enormous
amount of work to prevent and respond to
violence against women and we had
essentially private resources from a
foundation which are super helpful right
because they're not stuck in that
political machinery to start locally
driven essentially clinics or social
institutions that are combined with
medical professionals to provide kind of
clinical care as well as social and
emotional support to survivors and part
of the intention of that effort was that
those organizations would become
self-sufficient and so I had seen them a
long time ago when they started and I
was in Sierra Leone earlier this year
and saw them again they're called the
rainbow clinics and they're awesome
they're truly awesome they don't have
enough money to survive so they are
working to get available resources from
international donors or to get support
locally and they're really struggling to
survive so I think just to say the
reality is that they also need what we
all need in the system to deliver for
people and yet oftentimes they don't
have the kind of expertise in the
machinery of proposal writing and things
like that to thrive but there are many
examples of local partnerships so I
think yes huge resource there's been
quite a move to localize aid but at the
end of the day if we can't fix their
absorption capacity you know how they
can get money how they can attract that
money and how they can manage the
services that they're there to deliver
we're going to see the same kind of
pattern of more international agencies
than local jury thank you very much for
a very clear and critical presentation
which is also passionate with
presentation so could you join me in
[Applause]
[Music]